quiz world mais ce ne serait pas un
sommet des jeunes sur le climat sans le
visage phare du mouvement après avoir
manifesté avec des centaines de milliers
de personnes dans les rues de new york
la jeune suédoise à revêtir des habits
plus formelle pour siéger aux côtés du
secrétaire général de l'onu m les
dirigeants du monde ont un problème dit
il il parle beaucoup mais ils écoutent
très peu alors antonio guterres s est
venu écouter ce qu'avait à dire ces
jeunes des militants et des
entrepreneurs qui veulent faire une
différence we should have eyes united
politiques nous écoutent
parce que en fait on n'a plus le temps
le québécois est dit perez et parmi les
participants à ce sommet qui proviennent
de plus de 140 pays
il veut ramener un message d'urgence au
pays c'est que tous les partis
politiques devraient s'engager à
décarboniser complètement leur économie
le plus rapidement possible d'ici 2050
l'économie canadienne on a les
ressources on a les moyens ce qui manque
c'est la volonté politique
ce sommet a donné l'occasion aux jeunes
de confronter des géants qui les profits
sont ils plus important que nos vies
cette jeune femme demande à microsoft
pourquoi l'entreprise investit toujours
dans les énergies fossiles
c'est une conversation que nous devons
avoir répondent ils
comme celle qu auront une soixantaine de
chefs d'état lundi
invité à l'onu pour un sommet spécial
ils doivent présenter des plans de
réduction des émissions de gaz à effet
de serre